foreign
yeah um so we just lost the jet which is
super weird we probably shouldn't be
missing it happens all the time
what do you mean they're 80 billion
dollars sometimes you lose a jet or
eight billion how much is it how much is
an F-35 virtually like 80 million I
think I mean the amount of money that
goes into developing them too though
that's the thing but once they start
making them it's like they're what like
80 ml a pop well the military is now
searching for the wreckage of an F-35
fighter jet that crashed near Charleston
South Carolina the pilot
austiners took the pilot to a medical
facility to get checked out that pilot
is now in stable condition they say
so far no word on what caused the crash
I don't I don't care what caused the
crash I want how did we lose a jet
sometimes you lose a jet bro
oh you've never lost a jet
75 mil
cool depending on it's not just any
other fight today it's an F-35 fighter
jet it's one of the world's most
advances
you know honestly she does sound like
that but it's still racist
yeah
it's voiced by Hank Azaria
I was watching uh I was watching aw this
weekend I was watching the Thunder Rosa
one where he's like you're from Tijuana
she's like Tijuana and he goes yeah but
it feels racist when I say it that way
North Carolina Reports say there was a
mishap the pilot ejected and landed
safely but the jet is nowhere turns out
a bee got in the cockpit and he panicked
to be found
just panics he's just [__] panics
looks like the cell phone really works
are the US military oh she threw the
shade you see that looks like stealth
mode really works
throwing Chain man you're not allowed to
be funny this is Forbes you're a woman
and it's also India so much so that
they're asking the public for help it's
just like a large portion of your
population in your country like each
[__]
out of cow's asses yeah so for health
benefits so
what about the Curious Case of the
missing F-35 jet
it's a Twist straight out of a Hollywood
Blockbuster one that's left the US
military scratching its head America is
missing its prized F-35 fighter jet a
plane worth 80 million dollars the F-35
is a stealthy mob so basically it's
designed to disappear
but what happens when you design a jet
so stealthy that you end up losing it
yourself
the US is facing this dilemma right now
but how did the plane just disappear it
all began with a routine training
exercise in South Carolina it was a
Sunday afternoon a U.S military pilot I
don't even [__] with these anymore
everything's drones now why are even
[__] with manned aircraft at this
point honestly will mean is it because
we made so many of them that we're still
using them because we could because
we're still making more but that's my
point that we could accomplish
everything that we're doing now with
somebody in a strip mall without having
to put a pilot in there and they get the
planes could do the same thing you know
yeah but there is something to be said
for like having a human in a cockpit
that can make human decisions on the Fly
you're like I don't know I mean I get
what you're saying
in a drone okay but who cares
uh you should care when you have
carriers that you're launching the
drones from don't care
okay
don't care I don't care it doesn't
matter it's all gonna end up blown up by
the Chinese anyway yeah
it took his F-35 out for a spin
what happened next I don't think how it
went ma'am
hey you're just taking your F-35 out
before I spin hey can I get the keys I'm
gonna go around the block burn some
steam off I gotta run to 7-Eleven you
guys want anything
Landing a Harrier jet in a 7-Eleven in
Baltimore to get smokes
the US I love how Forbes India like
nobody in this office has any idea how
an actual military functions
so the pilot ejected himself out of the
jet
he survived and was taken to the
hospital but the jet simply vanished
has anyone looked for a humongous
Fireball or maybe like a crater as
Virgie said off the air we sold it to
like the cartel or something in reverse
engineering it yeah U.S military with a
unique problem a multi-million dollar
missing jet that simply gone off the
radar how great would it be if it
crashed in some [__] really based
like survivalist backyard they quickly
put the fire out and he's just like
pulling pieces off of us hiding it we're
so [__] our military's such an
embarrassment now we're so [__] we're
so [__] we're so far remember when we
were the [__] literally look at the
badass world's source of fear yeah
remember when we like we had like what a
good 30 40 years where we didn't even
have to use our military we just had it
and we would just show up to your
country with diplomats and go cut the
[__] and you go okay all right all right
okay
the current searches are around two
Lakes they're located north of
Charleston City everywhere planes
falling out of the [__] Sky man South
Carolina is like the Bermuda Triangle
for transportation have they looked at
South have they looked at South of the
Border did they land by the Mexican neon
light
how would you tell how could you tell I
don't know I thought it was just a ride
can't you tell it's already a smoldering
ruin yeah so Regulators maybe he wanted
to get illegal fireworks in the region
but they haven't had any luck so far
which prompted the US military to make
an unusual call
so nobody they put their phone they put
a phone number there you don't think
they're getting prank calls all day
about a fighter jet right now God damn
it my phone is dead [__] an appeal for
help I want to call him I want to call
them do it like uh when they were
looking for that cops missing gun in The
Wire yeah you're just interviewing all
these prisoners and he interviews one
and he goes does it have to be the cops
gun because of his guns you need I could
get you guns I want to call them and
just say that do you does it got to be
that F-35 because if you need fighter
jets I got you dog
they want the people to coordinate with
the military
basically what they're saying is find
the Jet and turn it in
yeah thank you for clarifying that
in the world well Indians are [__]
dumb huh you know there's just a lot of
them